this is actually super important
i think there's a lot of raw raw like
motivational speaker business advice out
there that is utter horseshit and
and i think one of the the biggest
delusions illusions or just hoaxes is
like optimism think big the passion is
going to drive you by like that's how
people are really successful or
successful that might be the story you
read about in the magazines because it
makes for a fun hero's journey type of
story
but
the
the people that that i've been most
impressed by
ask themselves all the time what is the
worst case scenario they're budgeting
for the downside
so in other in other words they're not
using optimism to allow them to take
action they're not just like you know
what i'm going to jump off the cliff and
grow wings on the right on the way down
or whatever the you know
the cliche is that you might find on
like a calendar and office space no
they're saying the way that i do things
that other people think are high risk or
other people think are risky dangerous
whatever it might be is because i
i write down
the worst case scenarios ask myself
what can i do to mitigate these things
from happening and then i ask myself if
they happen what can i do to get back to
where i am now and i realize these like
risky things are not risky at all right
they're totally reversible
they're just speed bumps if anything
goes wrong really in the grand scheme of
things and so they they get a lot of at
bats
they're really good at capping the
downside branson has said this you know
as much as he has a lot of rah-rah stuff
like you drill down into it it's like
he's really good at deciding like what
is the most i can lose if i do x what is
the most time that i can lose
if we do why
and then making decisions based on
that sort of
that
loss limit if that makes sense
so that's very heartening because i've
never been
i mean i would like to say i'm a follow
my passion kind of guy i get excited
about things i want to scratch my own
itch but i think that the real tool kit
is getting really good at asking you
know is this the condition that i so
feared what if
and and once you sort of neuter the
worst case scenarios
and uh de-power them you're like oh yeah
this is fine like this is totally fine
it's not any riskier than just like
investing and watching a new tv series
on netflix like maybe you get three
episodes and you're like damn it i can't
believe three hours of this crap
let me choose another series it's not
the end of the world
can i uh can i just make a comment on
before we go on to the next topic on
this risk-taking issue
because i think there's a very very
important lesson in my story
uh most people don't realize that when i
started sun
with scott mcnealy we started another
company a month earlier
and when i see audiences like this
i always ask them do you remember what
company i started and failed
and
nobody can tell it was a company called
the data dump
um
in my point is the following
your failures don't matter if they're
manageable failures
my life wasn't going to end if the data
damp failed
i'd be a little bit behind on my rent
but
i'd pick up and start again
and
and we started both data dump and sun
about a month apart
same founders
and my point is failure doesn't really
matter
if it's not going to kill you
success on the other hand everybody
remembers 40 years later
and it changes your life life and
frankly the failures also are probably
one of the more important learning
moments in your life
so i just want to emphasize
what seems like a large risk may
actually in the context of 10 20 or 30
years be a very small risk
because nothing about you changes maybe
you're a little bit smarter
yeah i mean i think you know buffett
says uh the focus really should be on
the downside
uh you know so you really have to make
sure that the downside is
very solidly protected
and if the downside is well protected
almost uh the upside almost takes care
of itself
uh so
so
you know when when i wrote the investor
and i wrote about the patel's i mean my
own my own experience as an investor as
an entrepreneur
and this is not just my experience it's
the experience of almost all
non-venture-backed startups so venture
back startups make up maybe one tenth of
one percent of all startups may be less
than that
non-venture-backed startups is what is
everything that drives the us economy
the non-venture bank status and so
the people who
start these businesses
everyone thinks they're risk takers
but they are the opposite of risk takers
entrepreneurs do not take risk
they do everything in their power to
minimize risk
and so they try to put the urge as much
in their favor
uh when they take this when they take
these
these bets so for example in my own case
when i started my business
i pulled thirty thousand for my for a
401k account
and i was 24 years old i wasn't worried
about my retirement savings at that
point and uh i took 70 000 in credit
card debt and and i researched uh
bank personal bankruptcy laws at the
time they've changed those laws since
then but at that time
if you declared bankruptcy
personal bankruptcy
pretty much
everything was cleansed
and you couldn't declare bankruptcy
again for seven years
which
actually meant that you became a better
credit
for people to give your credit card
themselves because they knew you
couldn't screw them again
they knew they got screwed once but they
knew they couldn't get screwed a second
time for at least seven years so you're
actually your credit improved so the way
i looked at it i said okay this hundred
thousand that i'm putting in let's say
it blows up let's say the business fails
right so i say the 70 000 is visa and
mastercard are my venture campus okay
and they are just great venture
capitalists they took no board sheets
they never asked me what i'm doing this
was beautiful and if it didn't work
i could just go and declare personal
bankruptcy and it'd be just wipe clean
and the 401k you know i'd get a job and
we'd rebuild that so and i was single at
the time and
when i left my job
my employer told me my boss told me
we would love to have you back if you
come back they said they told me
when your business fails they didn't say
if your business fails they told me
monish when your business fails
you can come back
we'll give you like a 20 raise we'll
give you a promotion
and you'll be all set we'll be happy to
have you back so i said this is great
okay the business fails i declare
bankruptcy
i go back to work i have a better pay so
where is the risk
right so this is how the brains of most
early stage entrepreneurs which are
non-venture-backed work
venture-backed guys they've got an iv
they're a different universe forget
about that so iv trips are really bad
for you because you know it's better to
spend your time
getting customers
than
trying to get some vc to fund you i
always feel it's better just get
customers so anyway what i'm trying to
say is that
early stage businesses most early stage
businesses that the entrepreneurs who
start them
do not take risk
they do everything in their power
to minimize risk and of course what
happened with me was the business never
failed i never went back to work i paid
visa mastercard off they got very
lucrative you know interest terms
everyone was happy you know no problems
so i think i think the same framework
comes across in investing because just
like you know as an entrepreneur you try
to minimize downside risk
the same thing in investing you should
always look at
what happens if things don't go the way
you're thinking what's the protection
because
you know capitalism is brutal
uh it's creative destruction
most businesses that get started won't
make it even if they make it they won't
go 10 years or 20 years
and
by the time a business enters the s p
500
it has already passed its one
you know so it's already the the
elements which will lead to its decline
are mostly already in place and very few
businesses last 50 years
almost no businesses last 100 years so
it's it's pretty hard
[Music]
you